ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 15
beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für arbeit und soziales ja
ich warte mal eben wenn sie sich bitte
etwas beeilen mögen mit dem sitzplatz
wechsel
das muss nicht sein denn das gibt mir
die gelegenheit ihnen wenigstens zwei
drei sätze zu sagen zu dem was jetzt
hier diskutiert wird und vor allem was
danach noch diskutiert wird nach dem
tagesordnungspunkt der jetzt gleich dran
ist nämlich die änderung des energie
sicherungs gesetzes das wird auch noch
mal interessant weil es natürlich wieder
im zusammenhang steht mit den
energielieferungen aus russland
und diversen sanktionen die damit
inzwischen in dem zusammenhang
aufgetreten sind das wie gesagt gleich
aber jetzt erst mal geht es um das thema
inklusive arbeitswelt der debatte die
jetzt beginnt in diesen minuten liegen
zwei anträge zur grunde einmal aus der
unionsfraktion der antrag trägt den
titel potenziale nutzen inklusive
arbeitswelt stärken und es gibt einen
antrag der linksfraktion mit dem titel
volle und wirksame partizipation von
menschen mit behinderungen und deren
organisationen garantieren also
inklusion ist jetzt das große thema in
den nächsten minuten im deutschen
bundestag und es beginnt ein sprecher
aus der linksfraktion
es ist tag ist mehmet ali aus der
spd-fraktion entschuldigung werden wir
die über diesen antrag der ja schon mal
gesprochen und ich hatte schon beim
ersten mal gesagt dass dieser antrag
grundsätzlich erstmal ein rundumschlag
von zusammengewürfelten vorschlägen und
forderungen sind die teilweise
wortgleich von verbänden übernommen
worden sind auch mit denselben
orthografischen tälern und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion wenn ich mich nicht so
ganz falsch erinnere ist das ja so dass
wir sehr lange zusammengearbeitet haben
ich denke an das bundes teilhabegesetz
ich denke an die letzten jahre
da fordern sie jetzt dinge wo man sich
dann doch so ziemlich wundert warum das
jetzt alles kommt im übrigen auch in der
öffentlichen anhörung sehr interessant
war dass mindestens aus einer sechs
vertretungs organisation sogar der
vorwand kam warum sie ausgerechnet jetzt
damit kommt das wundert doch ziemlich
und vor allem die progressiven punkte
die sie in ihrer forderungen haben zeigt
ja schon dass sie sehr lange mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben und den wunsch
haben nach sozialdemokratischer
inklusions politik
inhaltlich handelt es sich bei ihrem
antrag zwar um eine auflösung von kreta
maßnahmen zur unterstützung der
beschäftigung von menschen mit
behinderungen auf dem ersten
arbeitsmarkt aber wenn man dann doch
konkret hinschaut sieht man überwiegend
die arbeitgeber perspektive keiner der
20 punkte enthält tatsächlich eine
verpflichtung für arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber die dazu veranlassen
menschen mit behinderung einen
arbeitsplatz anzubieten
all jene master an welche verbindliche
vorgaben für unternehmen beinhalten und
und die stellung von arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer mit behinderung
wirklich stärken würden werden ja
schlicht und ergreifend ausgenommen
und wenn ich mir dann so ihren antrag
nochmal genauer anguckt ist es ja so bei
ihrem antrag haben sie ganz viele
progressive forderungen ich denke jetzt
an unsere regierungskoalition an das was
wir gemeinsam mit bündnis 90 die grünen
mit der fdp zusammen haben muss ich
ihnen sagen herr ehlers da freue ich
mich auf ihre zustimmungen die ganze
zeit dann in der zukunft als sie können
ja nichts anderes machen als unseren
anträgen in der zukunft zuzustimmen weil
dann machen sie sich erst recht sehr
sehr unglaubwürdig
aber
in diesem zusammenhang auch fleisch noch
so ein kleiner exkurs ich kann ihnen
auch eine sehr nette lektüre anbieten
was sie unbedingt mal lesen sollten die
lektüre heitz mehr fortschritt wagen von
den autoren spd fdp fdp bündnis 90 die
grünen auch bekannt als
koalitionsvertrag deshalb auch ein paar
wichtige ergänzungen vielleicht was wir
alles noch vorhaben wir werben wir
werden die einheitlichen ansprechpartner
innen und arbeitgeber weiter entwickeln
wir werden echte teilhabe am
arbeitsleben durch die einführung der
vierten stufe der ausgleichsabgabe
schaffen und diese mittel zur
unterstützung
und förderung der beschäftigung
einsetzen und auch einiges im übrigen
ausprobieren müssen ich glaube da wären
wir gar nicht drumherum kommen um auch
mal ein paar projekte zu wagen aber ich
möchte dass wir nicht nur bei ihrem
antrag belassen ich habe mir natürlich
auch den antrag der linken angeguckt und
die intention mir nochmal genau
durchgelesen und herr hellmann es ist ja
grundsätzlich so die intention ihres
antrages ist ja wirklich zu würdigen
aber eins stört nicht dann doch ziemlich
und das hatte ich glaube ich gestern
schon im ausschuss erwähnt dass mir da
einfach zu wenig fleisch am knochen ist
und dass wir da gerne auch gemeinsam
daran arbeiten können dass da auch mehr
fleisch am knochen kommen kann wenn sie
dann künftig unseren anträgen zustimmen
sie werden gut sagen keine sorge es ist
ja selbstverständlich so dass wir alle
uns mehr partizipation für menschen mit
behinderung wünschen aber in dem antrag
ist halt sehr sehr wenig präzision dabei
und deshalb freue ich mich dann auch
wenn wir dann in gemeinsame gespräch
eingehen und dann auch vieles
präzisieren können um aber auch hier
missverständnissen etwas vorzubeugen
auch hier empfehle ich die lektüre mehr
fortschritt wagen zu lesen und ein paar
erkenntnisse noch mal die wir vielleicht
auch im koalitionsvertrag noch mal
ausgeführt haben wir werden die mittel
des partizipations fonds erhöhen und
verstetigen wir werden auch einen
sprachendienst in einem engen
bundeskompetenzzentrum für leicht
umgebaut sprache einrichten und vom
bundesprogramm barrierefreiheit hat sich
ja schon mal gesprochen
und vielleicht noch mal zum duktus der
inklusion bei uns in der gemeinschaft
ich glaube auch dass hat sich gestern
erwähnt gehabt wer macht denn die
inklusion
kommt das aus der gesellschaft oder
machen es immer die menschen mit
behinderung oftmals ist es so dass die
menschen mit behinderung immer auf die
übrigen mitglieder der gesellschaft
zugehen müssen es sind die einrichtung
es in die sozialen dienste es sind die
freunde die eltern die inklusion machen
müssen aber zu wenig kommt von den
unternehmen zu wenig von den vereinen
die intention dass menschen mit
behinderung mitgenommen werden können
und da müssen wir ganz ganz viel machen
und auf der anderen seite meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ist es dann so
dann beobachtet man eben auch was
passiert mit diesen ausgleichsabgabe
mitteln ich gebe ihnen ein super gutes
beispiel aus baden württemberg ich habe
mir das auch heute noch mal kommen
lassen damit ich nicht
falsch ich erzähle mache ich ja nicht
und wenn man sich das näher anguckt dann
werden mitteln der ausgleichsabgabe
beispielsweise dafür eingesetzt dass 24
der wohnheime gebaut werden das muss man
sich mal reinziehen und dann steht ihnen
die förderbescheiden aus baden
württemberg bestes beispiel in den
förderbescheiden wohnheim für werth band
beschäftigte weil sie dann die
argumentation daher leid naja wenn in
diesem wohnheim wfbm beschäftigte und
dann kann man ja auch die
ausgleichsabgabe für 24 der wohnheime
ausgeben und wohnheime 24 der wohnheime
bei aller liebe das hat nichts mehr mit
selbstbestimmung zu tun in diesem
zeitalter so was gehört weg es wir
werden immer solche angebote draußen
aber die ausgleichsabgabe dafür
einzusetzen das gehört sich nicht und
vielleicht muss man auch hier darauf
hinweisen frau präsidentin ich bin
sofort fertig darauf hinweisen dass wir
auch nochmals die evaluation des bundes
teilhabe gesetzes angehen müssen und
dafür ist es umso wichtiger dass länder
angelegenheit ist dass wir in den
ländern soziale mehrheiten haben umso
mehr freue ich mich auf den sonntag dass
wir mehr sozialem erhalten
zusammenkriegen vielen dank herr
marquis mineralien aus der spd-fraktion
der beauftragte für die belange von
menschen mit behinderungen und denselben
auftrag hat auch wilfried bos ist der
nächste redner aus der unionsfraktion
war ein uhr nachts also versuchen sie
bitte doch ihre rede halten einzuhalten
sie haben ja genug minuten es folgt für
die cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege
wilfried erlass
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren das leben ist
wie eine schachtel pralinen
man weiß nie was man bekommt gewiss
kennen sie alle dieses zitat aus dem
film forrest gump der die persönliche
lebensgeschichte eines mannes mit einer
kognitiven behinderung erzählt ja die
erfolgreiche geschichte
und die erfolgreiche lebensgeschichte
weil er seine potenziale nutzen konnte
und dabei die entsprechende
unterstützung hatte was im film
spielerisch ja quasi federleicht
erscheint nämlich die berufliche
inklusion von menschen mit behinderungen
bedarf in der realität gewisser
anstrengungen stößt nicht
unwesentliche hindernisse und
schwierigkeiten zum beispiel vergehen
oft wochen bis geklärt ist welche träger
für die finanzierung von arbeitsplatz
ausstattungen assistenzen zuständig sind
und dies obwohl wir als gesetzgeber im
bereich inklusive arbeitsmarktpolitik in
den letzten jahren viele
dinge vorangebracht haben ein
fraktionsübergreifender ähnliche ziele
verfolgen dennoch bedarf es weiterer
verbesserungen zum einen braucht es eine
bessere unterstützung von arbeitnehmern
mit behinderung damit diese sich
entsprechend ihrer stärken und
fähigkeiten am ersten arbeitsmarkt
etablieren können zum anderen bedarf es
aber mehr kooperation mehr ansprache der
arbeitgeber mehr verzahnung der
förderinstrumente und eine stärkung der
digitalen teilhabemöglichkeiten
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode
haben wir hierzu die einrichtungen
einheitlicher ansprechstellen für
arbeitgeber beschlossen
ziel der trägerübergreifenden lotsen ist
es fördermöglichkeiten der beschäftigung
von menschen mit behinderung aufzuzeigen
damit besagte ansprechstellen zeitnah
aktiv werden können braucht es aber
einen konkreten zeitplan und eine gute
umsetzungsstrategien ich denke aber auch
an
rechtssicherheit von inklusions
betrieben zb bei der anwendung des
ermäßigten umsatzsteuersatzes für ihre
dienstleistungen und produkte bei der
inanspruchnahme von wirtschaftshilfen
bei der bevorzugten vergabe an diese
unternehmen durch öffentliche
auftraggeber und bei der notwendig
werdenden angleichung beim
nachteilsausgleich aufgrund der
anstehenden erhöhung des mindestlohns
auf 12 euro in der öffentlichen anhörung
hat die bg inklusions firmen diese
vorschläge aus unserem antrag
ausdrücklich begrüßt denn es läuft noch
nicht alles überall so gut wie hier
mitten in berlin zum beispiel im neuen
berliner humboldtforum wo das inklusions
unternehmen lebenswelten in einem
europaweiten verfahren die ausschreibung
für den dortigen gastronomiebetrieb
gewonnen hat zudem gilt es beim budget
für arbeit und beim budget für
ausbildungen die anwendungsmöglichkeiten
zu erweitern und die hand antragstellung
zu erleichtern und weitere brücken wie
die von uns vorgeschlagenen außen
ausbildungsplätze zu bauen damit
werkstatt beschäftigte den weg auf den
ersten arbeitsmarkt auffinden mit blick
auf die werkstattbeschäftigten ist es
auf den ersten die es eben nicht auf den
ersten arbeitsmarkt schaffen brauchen
wir aber auch die verbesserung der
einkommenssituation aller
werkstattbeschäftigten in dem das
arbeitsförderung geld und nicht der
grundbetrag mit dem ausbildungsgeld
steigt und nicht mehr gedeckelt wird
schließlich die digitalisierung darf für
menschen mit behinderungen nicht halt
machen und muss als chance verstanden
werden damit menschen mit behinderungen
noch besser auf dem ersten arbeitsmarkt
fuß fassen können wir brauchen daher
förderprogramme für barrierefreie
digitale kompetenzen und die
entsprechende infrastruktur
und die entsprechende infrastruktur am
ersten arbeitsmarkt und in
außerbetrieblichen bildungseinrichtungen
unsere vorschläge im antrag potenziale
nutzen inklusive arbeitswelt stärken
erhielten von den sachverständigen in
der öffentlichen anhörung überaus
positive bewertungen unsere vorschläge
bieten eine gute grundlage die situation
von menschen mit behinderungen auf dem
ersten arbeitsmarkt zu verbessern denn
es ist für unsere gesellschaft insgesamt
wichtig dass wir die potenziale der
menschen mit behinderung nutzen so
sowie core es kann
seine potenziale nutzen konnte und damit
die menschen mit behinderung nicht nur
mitten in berlin stichwort
humboldt-forum mitten in der
gesellschaft stehen sondern in ganz
deutschland wir werben daher um ihre
zustimmung herzlichen dank
wilfried eggers ist der beauftragte für
die belange behinderter menschen in der
cdu/csu-fraktion nächste rednerin in
dieser debatte in der es ja um die
belange behinderter menschen geht
insbesondere auch in der arbeitswelt des
corinna rüffer aus der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen die in ihrer
biografie vermerkt dass sie viele jahre
mit behinderten menschen gearbeitet hat
häufig haben abgeordnete und auch
regierungsvertreter von dieser stelle
aus betont dass die oberste prämisse
würde ich sagen der un
behindertenrechtskonvention
nichts über uns ohne uns in diesem land
gilt
gleichzeitig haben wir sehr häufig
erlebt dass die praxis des
regierungshandelns dem nicht ins sprach
fristen für die abgabe von
stellungnahmen zu komplexen
gesetzesentwürfen manchmal bei wenigen
tagen und das ist für alle verbände und
für alle die zur stellungnahme
aufgerufen sind natürlich eine zumutung
aber kleine selbst vertretungs
organisationen behinderter menschen die
in der regel wesentlich auf
ehrenamtliches engagement angewiesen
sind haben unter diesen bedingungen kaum
eine chance ihre expertise ernsthaft
einzubringen wie gravierend das sein
kann sehen wir gerade im aktuellen drama
um die vom bundesverfassungsgericht
geforderte gesetzgebung zur sogenannten
für den fall also dass zum beispiel
pandemie bedingt die
überlebensnotwendigen
intensivmedizinischen ressourcen nicht
mehr für alle ausreichend und
entschieden werden muss
und ich bitte um aufmerksamkeit der
überleben darf und wer sterben muss und
ich glaube nicht dass irgendein minister
oder irgendeine ministerin dieses
kabinetts ernsthaft auf die idee
gekommen wäre an der exp austria's das
heißt jeder zeit könnte jemandem der
stecker gezogen werden wenn ein anderer
kommt dessen
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit besser
eingeschätzt wird totschlag per gesetz
könnte man sagen ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand diese erwägung ernsthaft
angestellt hätte wenn man die
beschwerdeführerinnen und ihre selbst
vertretungen von anfang an in einem
ernsthaften beteiligungsprozess mit
einbezogen hätte
stattdessen hat man diese
gesellschaftlich so unglaublich
relevante debatte von anfang an
gesundheitspolitisch beengt und sie
wesentlich von denjenigen steuern lassen
die die verfassungsbeschwerde
ursprünglich verursacht haben privaten
medizinischen fachgesellschaften nämlich
sie erahnen wir finden das anliegen der
fraktion die linke absolut richtig ihre
forderungen sind aber im wesentlichen im
koalitionsvertrag verankert und wir
hoffen dass wir zusammen an einer
wirklichen partizipation behinderter
menschen in gesetzgebungsverfahren
darüber hinaus arbeiten werden und jetzt
zum antrag der union
ich halte gar nichts davon irgendwie
darüber zu lamentieren dort sie in 16
jahren regierungszeit nicht ausreichend
zeit gehabt hätten all das umzusetzen
was sie heute und auch beim letzten mal
an guten dingen vorgelegt haben und
darauf kommt es ja an dass die dinge die
in seinem antrag stehen gute dinge sind
denn wenn wir die inklusive gesellschaft
voranbringen wollen und ich lese ihren
antrag so brauchen wir alle kräfte in
diesem land denn es ist eine mammut
aufgabe die wir vor uns haben und da
können wir auch auf die unionsfraktionen
nicht verzichten deswegen herzlichen
dank super typ und der oilers und alle
anderen für diesen antrag in den letzten
jahren
ja keine akute krise die wichtel die
klimakrise die pandemie der
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und wir
werden diese großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit auf dauer nur dann meistern
können wenn wir alle menschen mitnehmen
und nicht zulassen dass gruppen
gegeneinander in stellung gebracht
werden und die entwicklung eines
inklusiven arbeitsmarktes auch und
gerade angesichts des demografischen
wandels ist dabei enorm bedeutsam denn
es geht darum unsere arbeitswelt so zu
gestalten dass immer mehr älter werden
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
gesund bleiben wir können und wollen auf
sie nicht verzichten
deshalb ist es notwendig das
betriebliche eingliederungsmanagement
wie im koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen
verbindlicher zu regeln prävention
rehabilitation und teilhabe belastung
viel stärker auf den arbeitsmarkt
auszurichten und das ist notwendig die
bis schwerbehindertenvertretung als ganz
wichtige ressource in den betrieben
endlich zu stärken sie sehen unser klima
reicht weit über den antrag der union
hinaus in der ersten runde zu ihrem
antrag habe ich ausgeführt dass entgegen
der gesetzlich bindenden vorgaben der
behindertenrechtskonvention immer mehr
menschen auf sonder welten die
werkstätten für behinderte menschen der
wiesn werden
viele von ihnen wünschen sich dass
nichts sie wünschen sich etwas anderes
irgendwo in deutschlands berichtete mir
eine mutter zieht ihre meine tochter
arbeitet bereits seit über 20 jahren in
einer behindertenwerkstatt ich
zwischenzeitlich auch aufgrund einer
psychischen erkrankung sie sagt sie
möchte auf den allgemeinen arbeitsmarkt
aber sie weiß sie kann es nicht und die
nächste rednerin natürlich möchte ich
außerhalb der werkstatt arbeiten aber
bin ich denn einem arbeitgeber zuzumuten
und ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
wenn sie das hören ja dass ein mensch
befürchtet anderen menschen nicht
zuzumuten zu sein und ich möchte sagen
ich finde das muss uns alle wütend
machen und wir müssen dieser person zu
rufen du musst du nicht empfinden du
hast ein recht zur inklusive arbeit das
muss dieses parlament als betroffenen
personen
wir haben noch alle möglichkeiten
regelungen zu finden nicht maßnahmen von
der stange anzubieten wegzukommen von
der ausschreibung bis hin zu personen
zentrierung ist so orientieren an den
guten beispiel der inklusions betriebe
dieses landauf landab gibt und es
einfach zu machen das wäre die aufgabe
dieser zeit eine wichtige aufgabe einen
inklusiven arbeitsmarkt eine inklusive
gesellschaft voranzutreiben herzlichen
dank
corinna rüffer weil das russische
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen hier geht
es weiter um weiter oben das thema
inklusive arbeitswelt zu grunde liegen
anträge aus den reihen der union als
auch aus der linksfraktion
nächster redner allerdings rooney
springer fdp-fraktion und sprecher für
arbeit und soziales jürgen polen unser
behindertenpolitischer sprecher zu ihnen
gesprochen leider ist er kurzfristig
erkrankte aber das thema ist eben zu
wichtig als dass man diese rede einfach
zu protokoll gibt und deswegen wird mir
die ehre zuteil die wesentlichen punkte
und positionen der auf die fraktion
vorzutragen
die zahlen es geht hier um die inklusion
von behinderten in den arbeitsmarkt sind
erschreckend seit jahren es ist ein
wichtiges thema und ich finde da können
sie ruhig ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit
zeigen dankeschön die zahlen sind
erschreckend seit jahren für den
menschen mit behinderung wesentlich
schwieriger einen arbeitsplatz als
menschen ohne behinderung und wenn wir
mal an die locker und politiker muss man
sagen dass das problem dadurch auch noch
verschärft wurde ich möchte erinnern
dass wir im ersten lok darin jahr 2020
einen anstieg der arbeitslosigkeit von
menschen mit behinderung hatten um zehn
prozent das ist das ergebnis ihrer
politik und das ist ein katastrophales
ergebnis und dafür sollte sich
eigentlich auch mal jemand rechtfertigen
das darf sich nicht wiederholen und
zugleich müssen wir natürlich zukünftig
andere und bessere anreize setzen wenn
es um die integration von behinderten
menschen in den arbeitsmarkt geht wir
haben vergangenen jahren vorschlag
unterbreitet das sogenannte bonus malus
system das unternehmen nicht nur
abgestraft werden wenn sie die
beschäftigten quote nicht erfüllen
sondern das unternehmen belohnt werden
wenn sie die quote über erfüllen und
zwar mit 250 euro monatlich
beschäftigte dieser antrag wurde von
ihnen abgelehnt was in gewisser weise
auch zeigt wie ernst dieses thema ist
offenbar nicht ernst genug
[Applaus]
jeder weiß doch dass unternehmen
marktakteure genannt besser auch anreize
reagieren als auf strafen das zeigt ja
im grunde auch der begrenzte erfolg bei
der ausgleichsabgabe also der straff
teil dieses unterfangens nur jedes
vierte unternehmen das eigentlich
verpflichtet wäre behinderte zu
beschäftigen tut das nicht das ist nicht
gerade ein erfolgsmodell meine damen und
herren fakt ist arbeitslosigkeit
belastet das leben von menschen schwer
das leben von menschen mit behinderung
wird noch ungleich schwerer belastet
obwohl es einen enormen mitteleinsatz
gibt um behinderte in den arbeitsmarkt
zu integrieren ist deutschland im
europäischen vergleich auf dem letzten
platz was die lücke angeht zwischen
menschen mit behinderung und menschen
ohne behinderung und das war der
modernen dessen armutszeugnis
außerdem muss man festhalten dass jeder
sechste
mensch mit behinderung in deutschland
über keinen schulabschluss verfügt
jedenfalls in der altersgruppe 25 bis 44
jahren und das ist eben auch ein grund
warum die teilhabe am arbeitsleben so
hinter der normalität zurück liegt der
der menschen die keine beschäftigung
haben auch hier gibt es also einen
grundlegenden handlungs betraf bei
bedarf auch hier könnte man eigentlich
mal eine zeitenwende fordern aber das
thema scheint ihnen nicht wichtig genug
zu sein generell muss umgedacht
umgedacht werden das ist also eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche vor allem eine
politisch wichtige aufgabe menschen mit
behinderung stärker in den fokus zu
rücken wir als fdp fraktion werden uns
weiterhin intensiv für eine chancen
verbesserung für menschen mit
behinderung in der arbeitsweise
einsetzen und weiterhin auch sinnvolle
vorschläge unterbreiten wie zb eine
ausweitung des budgets für ausbildung
und arbeit sowie eine existenzsichernde
entlohnung für die beschäftigten
unterstützen und da kommt man zu einem
wichtigen thema das sind nämlich
menschen mit behinderung die in
werkstätten beschäftigt sind wir reden
hier mal alle von menschenwürde sie
besonders gern und besonders viel aber
wie kann es eigentlich sein dass die
mehr die mehrzahl der
werkstattbeschäftigten mit dem was sie
verdienen den eigenen lebensunterhalt
nicht bestreiten können da läuft ihre
ständig wiederholte floskel die würde
des menschen ist unantastbar völlig ins
leere und dafür sollten sich auch
schämen
meine damen und herren es gibt viel noch
zu sagen zu diesem thema aber die
redezeit ist mit vier minuten eng
bemessen wir brauchen verbesserungen bei
der beim budget für ausbildung bei der
eingliederungshilfe wir müssen
entbürokratisieren und die
antragsverfahren und die zugänge zu
zuschüssen für arbeitgeber zu verbessern
verbessern wir als auf die fraktion
sagen ganz klar junge menschen vor allem
junge menschen mit behinderung müssen
gefördert werden wir brauchen sie als
fachkräfte von morgen auch das könnte
ein beitrag zur fachkräftesicherung sein
ich bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wenig bringen aber das aus der
fdp-fraktion wo er sprecher für arbeit
und soziales es und stellvertretend die
rede gehalten hat für einen erkrankten
kollegen hier geht's weiter mit jens
beeck aus der fdp fraktion
da ist ja teil habe politischer sprecher
da springe ich freue mich zunächst
darüber dass sie auch für die auch die
fraktion wenigstens in der zwanzigsten
wahlperiode betonen dass es ein
wichtiges thema ist und dass sie sogar
in der sache das eine oder andere
richtige gesagt haben aber wenn sich
irgendeine fraktion in diesem hause für
die dinge schämen muss die sie im
zusammenhang mit inklusions politik
schon veröffentlicht hat dann ist das
nur ihre und keine andere dieser diesem
hause und deswegen die stelle hätte man
sich tatsächlich vielleicht sparen
können sie waren in der 19 wahlperiode
auch schon dabei sie wissen wovon ich
rede aber wir kommen zu den anträgen der
linken und der union die sie eingebracht
haben zu der zentralen frage des
inklusiven arbeitsmarktes und auch da
und zur partizipation auch da sind wir
dankbar dass sie das getan haben denn
obwohl man mal sagen bei der ersten
einbringung hier haben es nahezu alle
reden zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt
ungewöhnlich genug in den youtube
channel best auf bundestag gebracht
waren alle ein bisschen erregt über die
frage wo sie ihre ideen eigentlich her
nehmen und warum sie den letzten 16
jahren nicht umgesetzt haben das haben
wir jetzt aber hinter uns gelassen
werden eine öffentliche anhörung zu
diesem thema gemacht die im übrigen
immer wieder gut ist es war nicht die
erste aber auch sie hat wieder
erkenntnisse gebracht und wir nehmen
noch einmal zur kenntnis
dass im rahmen der korona pandemie die
fortschritte die wir bis in die jahre
2018 19 noch hatten bei der integration
von menschen in den arbeitsmarkt die
teilhabe bedarfe haben noch einmal einen
deutlichen rückschlag erlitten hat
deswegen stellt sich die frage wie wir
den inklusiven arbeitsmarkt in
deutschland nach vorne bringen heute
noch einmal anders als zuvor wir haben
nach der korona pandemie aktuell eine
weitere krise mit der wir uns heute den
ganzen tag hier befasst haben auch in
der nächsten woche befasst haben
befassen werden auch da haben wir
weitere aufgaben der geflüchtete aus der
ukraine kommen auch mit teilhabe bedarf
und behinderung in unserer land auch da
ist noch nicht alles gelöst werden uns
auch mit vielen traumatisierten menschen
beschaffen müssen aber all diese krisen
ändern nichts daran dass wir uns
vorgenommen haben in einer fortschritts
koalition die dinge anzugehen die in den
letzten jahren liegen geblieben sind und
das werden wir tun umfassend auch bei
der frage des inklusiven arbeitsmarktes
und zwar das ganze portfolio betrachten
das fängt an beim betrieblichen wieder
eingliederungsmanagement und der
begleitung durch das hamburger modell
möglichst mit einer stärkung der
schwerbehinderten vertrauensleute in den
betrieben damit die menschen die noch
schon im arbeitsleben stimmt zu einer
behinderung kommen im betrieb verbleiben
können da haben wir deutlich luft nach
oben das geht weiter bei der frage der
inklusions unternehmen im ersten
arbeitsmarkt wir haben es aber beim
letzten mal ausgetauscht sie schlagen
vor auf der europäischen ebene etwas
einer mehrwertsteuer richtlinie zu
bewegen wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart wir wollen eine
umsatzsteuerliche privilegierung in
deutschland fest schreiben das werden
wir auch tun auf jeden fall sind wir uns
einig dass wir die inklusions
unternehmen deutlich stärken wollen weil
sie eine brücke im ersten arbeitsmarkt
sind
und wir gehen weiter auch über die frage
der modernisierung der werkstätten bis
hin zu ihm herüber kommen aus dem
wahlkreis heinsberg wo eine sehr
innovative werkstatt tätig ist ich
gerade auch versuchen durfte wo das
potenzial
zu einer deutlich hochwertigeren
beschäftigung zu kommen noch lange nicht
ausgereizt ist und wo wir vieles noch zu
tun haben um das zu ermöglichen auf das
werden wir tun weil wir alle nicht in
der werkstatt verbleiben wollen
ermöglichen möchten auf den ersten
arbeitsmarkt zu wechseln klammer auf das
darf dann sozialversicherungsrechtlich
kein nachteil sein wie das heute zum
teil noch wert ist auch das müssen
aber ebenso wollen belegen die in der
werkstatt sich wohlfühlen und dort
verbleiben wollen die perspektive geben
dort erstens nach ihren qualifikationen
tätig zu werden und die sind häufig
höher als das was heute passiert und wir
wollen zweitens auch das ist ein
päckchen das wir gemeinsam aus der 19
wahlperiode mitgenommen haben das
werkstatt entgelt zu reformieren dass es
erstens nicht auf den mindestlohn niveau
stehen bleiben muss und dass es zweitens
so ist dass ich von meiner arbeit der
vollzeittätigkeit in der werkstatt leben
kann auch das werden wir hoffentlich
gemeinsam angehen dass alles geht nur
in gemeinsamer bündelung unserer
kompetenzen und wenn wir uns daran dass
die inklusions politik auch in den
letzten wahlperioden diejenige war wo es
häufig einigkeit in diesem haus gegeben
hat begrüße ich ausdrücklich herr
kollege einer serie gehüpfe das und das
glaube ich tatsächlich wie konstruktiv
an diesem thema arbeiten können dass wir
mit dem ernst gemeinten angebot das in
ihrem antrag sich verbirgt wir den
fortschritt und zukunftsgedanken auf dem
koalitionsvertrag aber offensichtlich
auch von ihnen gemeint wirklichkeit
werden lassen in den nächsten jahren ich
freue mich an dieser stelle auf diese
zusammenarbeit mit
jens beeck aus der fdp-fraktion und noch
einer der ohne manuskript und
stichwortzettel auskommt
hier geht es weiter mit sören wenn man
das aber an dieser stelle weil wir uns
jetzt mit dem ende des heutigen
sitzungstages im morgigen tag deutlich
im morgigen tag befinden und erinnere
noch mal an die möglichkeiten die es
gibt um dem mitternacht wieder näher zu
rücken
das interesse
aller beschäftigten wir uns der
kolleginnen und kollegen natürlich
herzlichen dank dafür ich werde auch
streng sein deswegen das kennen sie
schon sümpelmann hat das wort für die
linke und sören feldmann ist sprecher
für inklusion und teilhabe in der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der vorliegende antrag der
unionsfraktion hat mich tatsächlich
überrascht und ich würde ihnen unter der
überschrift selbst abrechnung oder
erkenntnisgewinn einordnen
insbesondere sind in ihrem antrag gute
ideen für einen inklusiven arbeitsmarkt
enthalten aber wenn sie rückblickend auf
die neunzehnte 1817 der wahlperiode
zurückschauen werden sie feststellen da
gab es schon ähnlich gute vorschläge von
unterschiedlichen fraktionen hier aus
dem haus die jetzt vorgelegte
flickschusterei greift unserer meinung
nach deutlich zu kurz und insbesondere
warum erst jetzt diese ideen kommen die
vor wenigen minuten wenigen monaten noch
als sehr schlecht und nicht umsetzbar
angesehen wurden genauso wenig
glaubwürdig liebe ampelkoalition ich bin
ja sehr optimistisch was ihre
ankündigung betrifft ob der vielen
ankündigungen der ob wollte könnte und
wir prüfen aus dem koalitionsvertrag
bisher ist da leider noch nicht so viel
angekommen jetzt müssen sie endlich mal
liefern
ein beispiel wenn ich nicht am samstag
der durch gestochene corinna rüffer hat
es angesprochen durchgestochen der
gesetzentwurf des gesundheitsministers
patriarch plötzlich wurde das wegnehmen
von behandlungs instrumenten als post
rasch ins wird behoben das sorgt
insbesondere für massive verunsicherung
und für ängste bei menschen mit
behinderung hier wurde erneut unser
vertrauen in die politik bewusst
zerstört die dort vorgeschlagenen lösung
ist für uns als linke völlig
inakzeptabel dabei dachte ich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dass die ampel
als ire beteiligungs desaster zur triage
gelernt hat zum ersten internen
arbeitsgespräch des ministeriums wurden
aber nicht mal alle kläger seit ich
eingeladen ähnlich lief es auch bei der
anhörung
sonntags ausschuss weitere betroffenen
akteure wurden ebenfalls nicht beteiligt
so geht teilhabe nicht
wir haben und das begrüße ich dazu
erzählte fraktion elle arbeitsgruppe
gebildet in die ich viel optimismus
stecke aber aber daraus macht sich weder
die ampel oder die spd mit ihrem
gesundheitsminister etwas partizipation
von menschen mit behinderung spiel
scheinbar doch nicht die rolle von der
immer gesprochen wird alle alle von mir
angefragten verbände vereine haben mir
bestätigt dass sie zu dem jetzt in rede
stehenden entwurf keine inhaltlichen
zuarbeiten oder entwürfe gekriegt haben
oder irgendwelche anfragen auf
partizipation
das ist der falsche weg
und nehme
ampelkoalition sie werden damit auch
ihren ankündigungen nicht gerecht denn
im ergebnis heißt das partizipation von
menschen mit behinderung muss nach
auffassung der linken endlich
rechtskraft bekommen die vergangenheit
offenbart hier bereits weitere
erhebliche defizite corinna rüffer hat
sie angesprochen viel zu kurze fristen
texte nicht in leichter sprache und
wenig beteiligung mit dem heute hier
vorgelegten antrag der linken zur
folgenden wirksamen partizipation
könnten endlich notwendig in
verbindlicher rahmen verliehen werden
und liebe ampel koalition und
insbesondere liebe grün und liebe fdp
wir haben der letzten wahlperiode etwas
gemeinsam auf den weg gebracht einiges
davon steht in unserem antrag haben sie
den mut stimmt sie unserem antrag heute
zu das tut nicht weh danke
sören feldmann aus der links fraktion
die linke hat ja einen der beiden
anträge eingereicht die hier gerade zur
debatte stehen
außerdem der drittletzte redner in
dieser aussprache nach der aussprache
geht es ja weiter mit energiesicherheit
und zuständige minister sie haben mit
sicherheit schon gesehen robert habeck
ist auch schon da und recht regelmäßig
im gespräch wir sind angekommen bei
angelika glöckner aus der spd-fraktion
sie ist mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales
mit behinderung ich erkenne an dass ihre
anträge in teilen durchaus wichtige
impulse setzen und es wurde auch viel
gelobt der antrag von der union ich will
aber mal sagen trifft der antrag in
seiner gesamtheit doch wirklich die
erwartungen von menschen mit
behinderungen ich habe viele gespräche
geführt mit menschen von behinderungen
und ich will auf vier punkte eingehen
die mir immer wieder genannt wurden die
ich jetzt in dieser debatte auch noch
gar nicht gehört habe
erstens menschen mit behinderungen haben
die erwartung dass sie selbstbestimmt in
ihren eigenen vier wänden wohnen können
für uns bedeutet das als gesetzgeber
wohnraum schaffen ohne barrieren das
gilt für neubauten genauso wie bei den
bestand sanierungen und ich bin daher
sehr froh und ich will das auch noch mal
hervorheben dass wir da in unserem
koalitionsvertrag
wichtige punkte vereinbart haben um eben
deutschland unser land barrierefrei zu
gestalten damit wir eben mit blick auf
wohnen mehr barrierefreiheit erreichen
und auch als vergleich beispielsweise
dem antrag der union kein wort von
barrierefreier
wohnmöglichkeit nichts davon erwähnt der
nächste punkt
zweitens menschen mit behinderungen
wollen auch mobil seien menschen mit
behinderungen wollen reißen wie ist es
denn momentan 24 stunden vorher müssen
sie sich anmelden bei der deutschen bahn
ehrlich gesagt ich finde das ist aus der
zeit gefallen und es wird zeit dass wir
da mehr tun für selbstbestimmung von
menschen mit behinderungen wir haben sie
im koalitionsvertrag wurde
im antrag der union nichts davon zu
lesen drittens menschen mit
behinderungen das wurde mehrfach erwähnt
wollen zu recht eine bessere integration
in den arbeitsmarkt und ja es ist
eindeutig auch gute löhne wir werden das
werkstatt entgelt detailliert über
arbeiten und wir wollen kein flickwerk
wie die union es in ihrem antrag
vorgeschlagen hat und was wir auch tun
ich will es auch nochmal erwähnen der
mindestlohn wird auch viele menschen mit
behinderungen nutzen es geht ja an den
menschen mit behinderung nicht vorbei
dass wir ab oktober den mindestlohn
anbieten werden aber zu den instrumenten
budget für arbeit budget für ausbildung
es ist eben auch sehr wichtig dass wir
diese instrumente weiter ausbauen und
weiterentwickeln sie haben es auch
genannte oehlers betriebe sollen besser
beraten werden dass es wichtig dass
unternehmen die beratung erhalten auch
das haben wir in unserem
koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen vielen dank
dafür dass sie diese punkte auch
übernommen haben sie haben dass ben
genannt das habe ich auch ausgeführt es
ist wichtig dass die menschen auch im
arbeitsprozess bleiben und uns als
fachkräfte nicht verloren gehen deswegen
ist es absolut notwendig und wir werden
das tun dass wir das beim verbindlicher
ausgestalten
ich wieder aber auch noch sagen wovon
sie überhaupt nichts gesagt haben und es
ist nun mal fakt dass es viele betriebe
gibt die ihrer beschäftigungspflicht
nicht nachkommen obwohl sie menschen mit
behinderung beschäftigen müssen und ich
will ihnen mal was sagen kein wort davon
haben sie in ihrem antrag in der letzten
wahlperiode haben sie sich verweigert
eine vierte stufe der ausgleichsabgabe
einzuführen sie haben einfach nicht den
mut auch den arbeitgebern die ihren
verpflichtungen nicht nachkommen mal auf
die füße zu treten wir haben den wir
werden eine vierte stufe bei der
ausgleichsabgabe einführen viertens will
ich auch mal sagen dass es total wichtig
ist dass menschen mit behinderung und
ihre angehörigen bei den behörden im
umgang mit den behörden die beratung und
die antragstellung es so einfach wie
möglich gemacht bekommen wie es eben nur
geht ich weiß bin persönlich auch
betroffen durch meinen vater und ich
weiß sehr genau wie vor nicht der rede
es ist einfach sehr sehr wichtig und wir
haben das ja auch eingeführt mit dem
bundes teilhabegesetz dass wir sozusagen
leistungen gewähren wollen wie aus einer
hand und das ist das setzt nicht nur auf
papier steht und es funktioniert ist es
sehr gut dass wir jetzt festgehalten
haben im koalitionsvertrag dieses
umfassende regelwerk zu evaluieren denn
nur so kann es vor ort auch
funktionieren
und natürlich werden wir auch digitale
antragsverfahren auf den weg bringen was
sie von kolleginnen kollegen von den
linken gesagt haben das ist auch alles
richtig und wichtig aber insgesamt muss
ich sagen unser koalitionsvertrag ist
weiterführende er ist ganzheitlich
betrachtet und deswegen werden wir ihre
anträge ablehnen aber ich fordere sie
sehr gerne auch schließen sie sich
unseren vorhaben an filtern angelika
glöckner aus der spd-fraktion in der
debatte über inklusion in der
arbeitswelt und angelika glöckner folgt
der letzte redner hubert hüppe aus der
unionsfraktion von 2010 bis 2014
beauftragte der bundesregierung war für
die belange von menschen mit
behinderungen
mehr menschen mit behinderungen müssen
eine echte chance auf einen
ausbildungsplatz haben und einen job im
ersten arbeitsmarkt und deswegen haben
wir mehrere konkrete vorschläge gemacht
ich gebe zu es ist nicht alles drin das
wird ja auch von der spd kritisiert
während nicht alles drin die grünen
haben gesagt er war zwar nicht perfekt
aber gut die fdp hat ja gesagt hat
seinen eigentlich ihre forderung
trotzdem sagen wir nein sagen sie doch
einfach ja wenn das so gut ist oder
ergänzen die es dann wir haben wir einen
schritt weiter in der inklusion meine
damen und herren
weil damen und herren wir haben
jede menge fort wir haben jede menge
vorschläge gemacht insbesondere bei der
beruflichen bildung weil es uns wichtig
ist dass gerade junge menschen mit
behinderung eine chance haben im ersten
arbeitsmarkt und dass sie nicht
unbedingt in eine sonder einrichtung
müssen weil wir eben erlebt haben und
das zeigen die zahlen sind sie einmal in
der sonder wird kommen sie aus dieser
sonder wird so gut wie nie wieder raus
und deswegen müssen wir da etwas tun man
damen und herren und biss dann sage ich
ihnen auch ganz deutlich
das budget für ausbildung muss
verbessert werden es kann nicht sein
dass wir in den ersten 17 monaten 19
monaten gerade mal 31 budgets
vereinbarungen haben und da kann man
auch konkret was machen es muss zum
beispiel auch dann möglich sein dass
jemand ein budget für ausbildung bekommt
wenn der mensch mit behinderung keine
vollausbildung machen kann und keine
werke ausbildung sind dann gehört er ja
eigentlich auch gar nicht in die
werkstatt was ein mensch der eine
vollausbildung machen in der werkstatt
deswegen müssen wir auch menschen eine
möglichkeit geben die nicht in der lage
sind eine vollausbildung zu machen damit
sie hinterher auch ein job im ersten
arbeitsmarkt bekommt und zweitens die
betreffende person braucht die zusage
für das budget bereits vor dem
ausbildungsvertrag nicht hinterher denn
welcher unternehmer verlässt sich denn
daraufhin eigentlich weiß auf den
tatsächlich hinter das budget genehmigt
wird und das dritte ist
mir wäre es am liebsten dass wir den
eingangs und berufsbildungsbereich
grundsätzlich als budget fähig machen
dann kann jeder mensch mit behinderung
jeder jugendliche mit behinderung selbst
entscheiden gehe ich auf den ersten
arbeitsmarkt nämlich dieses geld mit und
setzte es entsprechend ein oder gehe ich
ihnen die sonder würde
und bin ich wenn ich gerade dabei bin
bei der beruflichen bildung wenn sich
irgendwo bis auf die berufsbildungswerke
wenn sich irgendwo die sachverständigen
eigentlich waren war es da wo das eben
die rehabilitations pädagogische
zusatzqualifikation ein hindernis für
die betriebe ist und dass sie unsere
forderung richtig finden wenn diese
zusatzqualifikation
gestrafft wird kostenlos und freiwillig
für die betriebe ist liebe freunde wir
wollen auch woher meine damen und herren
aber das war eben alles so gesehen habe
ich dieser freunde gesagt die ein
weiterer schwerpunkt ist dass wir
tatsächlich den reha auftrag den haben
nämlich die werkstätten für menschen mit
behinderung stärken wurden und
deswegen möchten wir auch
erreichen dass der übergang von der
werkzeuge in den ersten arbeitsmarkt
einfacher wird und dafür meine damen und
herren brauchen wir andere anreize es
muss sich für eine werkstatt lohnen wenn
sie es schafft einen menschen mit
behinderung in den ersten arbeitsmarkt
zu vermitteln
heute ist es noch so dass es sie für sie
wirtschaftlich eher schlechter ist und
deswegen müssten die anreize an das
gesetz werden ich möchte wir uns das
macht mir sorgen noch eins sagen die
tagesgeld plätze werden immer mehr das
sind plätze für menschen mit sehr
schweren behinderung die dann nicht die
auf erlaubnis bekommen im ersten in der
in der werkstatt zu arbeiten und werden
dann noch einmal
ausgesondert und ich bin an dieser
stelle der landesregierung nordrhein
westfalen sehr dankbar dass sie das
einzige land ist wo diese menschen das
recht haben auch in einer werkstatt zu
arbeiten und bin sicher dass herr
laumann als arbeitsminister das so
weiterführen will das ist einfach so
meine damen und herren und jetzt noch
ein netzes zur ausgleichsabgabe wir
wollen dass das gilt was am ersten
arbeitsmarkt gewonnen wird weil menschen
nicht bei unternehmen nicht genug
menschen mit behinderung beschäftigen
auch wieder für menschen mit behinderung
nur im ersten arbeitsmarkt ausgegeben
wird und deswegen muss ich ihnen sagen
herr mehmet ali
es ist ihr minister
hubertus heil der den ausgleich von
bearbeitung der dafür verantwortlich ist
nur das thema ist und es ist schon
komisch wenn sie sagen wir brauchen da
mehr für inklusiven arbeitsmarkt aber
derselbe minister das gutachten für das
immerhin 700.000 euro kostet für den
werkstatt honorar für die veränderung
des werkstatt wohnen eben nicht aus
steuergeldern sondern aus der
ausgleichsabgabe
gezahlt wird das meine damen und herren
ich nicht in ordnung und deswegen
arbeiten sie mit wir unterstützen sie
wenn sie inklusive hätten die inklusive
vorschläge machen viele
hubert hüppe bei relatio redner in
dieser debatte zum thema inklusive
arbeitswelt über beide anträge die hier
vorgelegen haben und wird jetzt
abgestimmt und sie haben im hintergrund
schon gemerkt katrin göring eckardt die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin ist ein klein
wenig ungeduldig wenn redner hier ihre
zeit überziehen das hat damit zu tun
dass wenn alle reden wir reden dürften
das ganze hier bis 1 uhr 20 31 in der
nacht gehen könnte deswegen hat sie
vorhin schon mal vorsichtig darauf
verwiesen dass reden auch durchaus mal
zu protokoll gegeben werden können